go to what dinesh said when dinesh was
on with us and i did the interview this
is exactly what i said i don't know why
the right isn't doing this we talked
about this on our interview
maybe a year and a half ago
he says tweets are fine elon musk but
you can dramatically change political
and cultural landscapes this way buy and
take over a major social media platform
acquire or create a tv network like abc
nbc or cbs create a world-class online
university and offer degrees for free
that's exactly what we talked about in
the interview can you pull up that
shortcut we replied with interest
to pull up that shortcut with uh dinesh
and i because i fully agree with that i
can i would like to reply to that tweet
i'm banned on twitter so i cannot do so
but i can make a comment right now go
for it my comment is if you're a
businessman
you'd have to you'd have to do it as a
philanthropic thing if your job is to
generate a profit it will not help
if you want to tell the truth if you
want to be a news organization the
commercial imperative
if elon musk is listening the commercial
imperative that is to say poor
for-profit capitalism
is incompatible with investigative
journalism you have to be philanthropic
and by the way this is the way it used
to be you talked about journalism in 70s
and 80s from what i've read
those organizations it was a lost leader
on the company's balance sheet so abc
news would do these things says buy abc
and all these
they would do it but they would do it as
a loss leader they would they would
almost donate money on their balance
sheet profit and loss to do the work it
didn't generate a profit per se
but they donated it and if you're going
to buy these companies
it's not going to help unless the person
is willing to be philanthropic the
billionaire would have to uh uh you
don't think so you don't think so i i i
i believe this yes i i know so i i don't
think and it's self-evident i mean these
billionaires settle losses i don't know
if i agree with that because because
then you're saying
then you what you just said is that the
current mainstream media has zero
influence and they do mark benihoff
bought time magazine that's a pretty
legit one to buy well you know you got
the uh the peter guy about l.a times you
got the
amazon jeff bezos bob wapo if it doesn't
work why are they buying well maybe
maybe we're talking about different
things i mean to say if you want to do
investigative journalism if you just
want to people opine and speak opinion
and project their political if i don't
know if that's what the next decision
means i don't want to put words in his
mouth but if the idea is you just want
to buy a network so that you can
project your political views onto your
audience that's not what i'm talking
about i'm talking about doing real
information finding in truth gathering
investigative reporting you know do
those networks even do investigative
reporting anymore i guess maybe nbc
catches the predators or
does what would you do i don't know but
i mean really real journalism requires
philanthropy so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]